well it's always helpful to take a
closer look uh with the help of a map
here of what is actually happening on
the ground in ukraine with me now again
in the studio is the military expert and
veteran british army tank commander
justin crump who is also chief executive
of siberline as well um justin i was
saying in the introduction to that
report there by stuart that uh russia is
running short of precision missiles
perhaps you could just enlighten us as
to actually what that means and
particularly what the implications are
yeah and this is actually part of the
campaign um russia's been waging against
the cities obviously we're looking there
at the donbass and we'll come back to
that but throughout all the conflict
russia has been launching longer-range
strikes against cities railway lines
infrastructure
grain infrastructure food of course a
big factor and these particular missiles
they've been using at the moment
technically anti-shipping missiles they
have an anti-land capability as well but
they're based in crimea predominantly to
stop enemy ships now i guess russia is
figuring there aren't that many enemy
ships to deal with
so they are using these missiles and
their secondary role of land attack but
they're not brilliant at that
it's a further indication of how russia
is having to
use everything at its disposal to keep
achieving its ends i'd hesitate to say
they're running really short of
munitions as a result of this
they are suffering certain shortages but
i think it just shows how they're
throwing everything into the fight
that's really where it's more important
to me interesting
also the focus of the world's media
recently sort of moved away uh from
mariupol and so i'm just going to invade
your space software
the focus has been there on several
donetsk hasn't it just explain why
that's so important and what is going on
there the reason that severe.net is
important there's heavy street fighting
still here um it's the last part of
luhansk blast you can just see the
boundary here which ukraine holds so for
ukraine it's really symbolic
to be holding this last bit of territory
in luhansk last they haven't given up
the oblast russia can't say it's taken
all of it for russia though the big
fight here is their effort to destroy
the ukrainian armed forces that's one of
their war aims is to demilitarize
ukraine and they've always thought they
could do it by
taking the real best part of the
ukrainian military in the donbass and
trying to cut them off it's been a war
aim since day one they started trying to
encircle right in depth down there in
this side of the map
they've had to come in smaller and
smaller and finally everything's focused
on this end of the salient now um so
hence so important for both sides and
for russia it's all about trying to
grind down the ukrainian military at
this point and so what would a fall of
severity actually look like you know
it's a hard city to defend because it's
on the other side of the river from mr
chansk so it's what on the what we call
the far bank for ukrainian forces rather
than the home bank and as it sounds home
is safe far is enemy dominated so they
have to get back across the river to
lissa chansk good place to defend on
high ground but you can see that russia
has been trying to cut off that area for
a while they have this very threatening
group of forces here they've failed
across the river in the north before we
talked about that a few weeks ago but if
they do manage to threaten this area
more you have to fall back quite some
way and that's really difficult at this
point in the conflict for ukrainian
forces so next line is bakmut and then
actually further to the west around here
where the major cities are in donetsk
but going back that way that's when
you're most exposed if you have a little
bit of time in this conflict you dig
trenches you're sheltered you can hold
your ground as ukraine has done when you
get driven out of those you're
vulnerable so it's a time of great
danger for the ukrainians i think
especially when lissa chansk
comes under really sustained pressure
all right certainly one that we need to
be keeping our eye on isn't it justin
thank you very much indeed